Tag zusammen herzlich Willkommen zu ZDF
heute live eurem Livestream zu aktuellen
Ereignissen und da müssen wir heute mal
wieder nach Nordrhein-Westfalen schauen
denn am Vormittag hat es im CHEMPARK
Leverkusen eine schwere Explosion
gegeben das ist nach Angaben der
Betreiber einer der größten Chemieparks
Europas und dort sind in verschiedenen
Standorten mehr als 70 Firmen angesellt
und in einem
müllverbrennungswerk in einer
Verbrennungsanlage soll es zu einer
Explosion gekommen sein mit wohl
mehreren Verletzten aktuell werden auch
noch Menschen vermisst über der Stadt
ist eine große Rauchsäule zu sehen
gewesen und wir schalten jetzt zu meinem
Kollegen Heiko Rams der sich in die Nähe
des unglücksors begeben hat um mal zu
schauen wie es dort aussieht Heiko
so wir wollten erstmal nach Bildern
gucken
das heißt wir schauen uns erstmal was
genau an Liebe Regie
gut dann haben wir erstmal die aktuelle
Berichte die letzten Neuigkeiten zu
diesem Unglück und was schauen wir uns
erstmal zusammen an
also da ist Leverkusen
[Musik]
und dort ist der Chempark in der Stadt
und wenn man mal näher rangehen können
wir auch sehen
was dort genau ist
so ich würde sagen wir schalten mal zu
Heiko Heiko du bist so nah dran Gefahren
wie es geht was kannst du uns sagen bist
du tatsächlich in der Nähe des
Chemieparks
ja genau ich bin einige hundert Meter
vom Chemiepark entfernt und zwar
befindet der sich hinter mir dort auf
diesem Hügel und rechts davon wo dieser
Schornstein zu sehen ist das ist der
Chemiepark und das ist auch genau die
Stelle wo bis vor wenigen Minuten noch
eine Rauchsäule zu sehen war dort hat
sich um 9 Uhr heute morgen das Unglück
ereignet und zwar soll es noch nach
unbestätigten Berichten eine Explosion
in einem Tanklager nahe der
Verbrennungsanlage und nahe diesen
Betrieben der chemischen Industrie
gegeben haben dieser Brand breitete sich
aus es kam auch zu dieser Explosion und
die Feuerwehr hat es dann geschafft den
Brand zu löschen die Gefahr war bis vor
wenigen Minuten das einzelne Brandherde
auf benachbarte tanklagerübergreifen und
das ist dann noch zu einer weiteren zu
einer größeren Explosion kommen könnte
aber diese Gefahr scheint im Moment
gebannt die
die wir bisher erfahren ist allerdings
schon erschreckend genug es gibt 12
verletzte es gibt leicht verletzte davon
dann noch zusätzlich vier
Schwerverletzte und fünf Arbeiter des
Betriebes werden zurzeit noch gesucht
Meldungen wonach einige Arbeiter oder
zwei Arbeiter gestorben sein sollen sind
allerdings nicht bestätigt von da aus
gehen wir erstmal nicht davon aus
sondern wir sehen im Moment nur diese
Bilanz und eine relativ ungeklärte
Gesamtsituation ist denn jetzt schon
klar was genau explodiert ist also um
was es sich dort handelt
nein kann man noch nicht genau sagen es
gibt widersprüchliche Meldungen der
Chemiebetrieb redet allerdings davon
dass es ein Tanklager gewesen sein soll
von dem aus dann die Gefahr ausging im
Moment Rücken auch hier bei uns
Rettungskräfte an und die versuchen sich
erstmal mal ein Überblick über die
gesamte Situation zu verschaffen es ist
noch nicht ganz klar um 14 Uhr soll es
eine Pressekonferenz geben und dann
werden wir näheres zu diesem Unglück
erfahren jetzt hast du gerade schon
gesagt also das Feuer scheint erstmal
gelöscht die Rauchwolke die hinter dir
zu sehen war als wir noch nicht live
waren die ist mittlerweile verschwunden
kann man denn noch was riechen jetzt da
wo du gerade stehst
nee an dieser Stelle nicht da würde der
Segler sagen kann auch nicht weil ich
befinde mich auf der Luvseite also auf
der Wind zugewandten Seite des
Unglücksortes auf der leserseite also
auf der Wind abgewandten Seite da sieht
das etwas anders aus es gibt eine
Rauchwolke vom Feuer die zieht in
Richtung Bergisches Land und deshalb
haben die Behörden auch gesagt Vorsicht
Vorsicht für die Bewohner die dort leben
sie soll nach Möglichkeit sich in
geschlossene Räume zurückziehen sie
sollen die Fenster sie sollen die Türen
verriegeln und auf jeden Fall auch bitte
die Klimaanlagen ausschalten damit sie
nicht in Kontakt kommen mit diesem Rauch
letzten Meldungen zufolge ist in einigen
Kilometern Entfernung die
Gesundheitsgefahr schon nicht mehr so
akut das heißt die Feuerwehr warnt nicht
mehr davor direkt mit dem rauche in
Kontakt zu kommen aber der Sicherheit
halber sollte man sich doch in
geschlossene Räume zurückziehen die
Warnung gilt bis Solingen bis ins
Bergische Land Richtung wuppertal
das heißt also alles ich sag mal
östlich von Leverkusen ist derzeit noch
sozusagen Risikogebiet
ja kann man sagen und es war dieses
Risikogebiet wandert quasi mit der
gerade herrschenden Windrichtung und
verändert sich noch ein bisschen aber je
weiter das von dem eigentlichen
Unglücksort entfernt ist desto mehr
verdünnt sich ja auch diese
schadstoffwolke und die Gefahr für die
Anwohner nimmt ab aber in den genannten
Gebieten sollte oder raten die Behörden
trotzdem noch zu Vorsicht wir können mal
kurz auf meinen Rechner schalten ich
habe mir noch mal die Karte hier auf
mein Desktop gelegt dann können wir kurz
drauf gucken hier genau Leverkusen liegt
also südlich von Köln und wenn wir näher
rangehen da sehen wir auch schon da ist
die Explosion im Camp Park und wie der
Kollege gerade gesagt hat also hier
Richtung Solingen Remscheid Bergisch
Gladbach ist quasi alles hier auf der
Karte geografisch nicht ganz korrekt
rechts von Leverkusen dort sieht es die
Rauchwolke hin was genau explodiert ist
welchen Schaden da welcher Schaden
entstanden ist ist derzeit noch nicht
richtig klar Heiko ne also da kann dass
sie alles drin sein weil da wurden ja
auch vor allem chemische Abfälle
entsorgt mich richtig verstanden habe
ja genau wir befinden uns hier
aneinander wirklich sehr sehr sensiblen
Stelle wir können zum einen sehen dieser
Berg dort hinten das ist kein normaler
Berg sondern es handelt sich hierbei um
eine Giftmülldeponie wir stehen am Rande
quasi an der Oder der größten
Giftmülldeponie in Europa zu meiner
Rechten befindet sich auch eine Brücke
das ist eine Rheinbrücke in Leverkusen
die Leverkusener Rheinbrücke der A1 und
diese Rheinbrücke wird neu gebaut man
sieht das hinter mir sind Bauarbeiten in
Gange es werden Löcher gerade gebohrt in
diese Giftmülldeponie da ist auch unklar
ob damit eine gewisse Gefährdung
verbunden ist also das ist hier alles
kein einfaches Gebiet es ist alles
erheblich vorbelastet und wenn dann
dieser Stelle ein Brand ausbricht oder
eine Explosion unkontrolliert ist dann
heißt das für die rettungs- oder für die
Behörden heißt das einfach nur absolute
Vorsicht hier muss man wirklich sehr
sehr sensibel sein und extrem aufpassen
damit die ganze Sache nicht
unkontrollierbar wird und größer wird
aber danach sieht es darauf das möchte
ich noch mal betonen im Moment nicht aus
also wir wollen noch mal zusammenfassen
für alle die sich gerade dazu geschaltet
haben heute morgen 9:40 Uhr kam es zu
einer Explosion im Chempark in
Leverkusen Heiko fast auch noch mal ja
die Fakten zusammen die wir bis jetzt
wissen
ja um 9 Uhr kam es so gibt es der
Betreiber des chemparkes des camparkes
an Tor einer Explosion in einem
Tanklager als stieg eine Rauchwolke
empor diese Rauchwolke war giftig und
zog in Richtung Bergisches Land die
Anwohner die zwischen dem Unglücksort
und dem Bergischen Land liegen sollen
bis jetzt alle Fenster Türen geschlossen
haben sie sollen sich in geschlossene
Räume bewegen und sie sollen auch auf
jeden Fall die Klimaanlagen ausschalten
es gibt insgesamt 12 verletzte dann gibt
es noch vier Schwerverletzte fünf
Menschen werden vermisst Meldungen
wonach zwei Arbeiter dieses Betriebes
gestorben sein sollen sind bisher
unbestätigt da werden wir wahrscheinlich
näheres auf einer Pressekonferenz in
wenigen Minuten erfahren
so jetzt bin ich gerade auf meiner
geografischen mangelkenntnisse
hingewiesen worden ich hatte nämlich
Norden und Süden verwechselt also
Leverkusen liegt natürlich nördlich von
Köln nicht südlich von daher dass es das
müssen wir mal kurz betonen aber
Leverkusen ist relativ nah dran an Köln
war auch zeitweise glaube ich mit in
dieser Gefahrenzone oder Heiko gab es da
auch Meldungen dass die Kölner auch
erstmal vorsichtig sein sollen
ja klar zwangsläufig ich befinde mich
hier auf Kölner Stadtgebiet und wenige
100 Meter von mir ist dann die
Stadtgrenze dort beginnt Leverkusen hier
geht eine Stadt in die andere über und
je nachdem wie der Wind sich gerade
verhält ist natürlich für alle Bewohner
dort ein gewisses Gefahrenpotenzial
vorhanden so ich schaue noch mal kurz in
die Kommentare also ich habe tatsächlich
auch hier einen Zuschauer der angibt
dass er das mitbekommen hat ich musste
mal kurz suchen wo er war also es
schrieb also es gab richtig heftige
Explosion hier
nervosny schreibt das wir können mal
kurz auf meinen Rechner schalten ich
wohne in Zentrum der Explosion war um
9:37 Uhr die Druckwelle war heftig hätte
fast die Fenster rausgehauen das sind
glaube ich auch Augenzeugenberichte die
ich mehrfach schon gesehen oder gelesen
habe oder Heiko
ja davon hören wir auch die Explosion
muss wirklich heftig gewesen sein und
die detonationswelle brachte hier
wirklich einige Fenster zum Wackeln aber
wir haben nichts vom weitergehenden
Schäden gehört außerdem Feuer auf dem
Betriebsgelände so hier gibt es auch
noch Menschen die jetzt angeben dass sie
dort arbeiten das können wir jetzt nicht
verifizieren Tobias schreibt der
arbeitet dort die Explosion war sehr
stark es gibt aber ja auch eine
Werksfeuerwehr vor Ort wissen wir schon
wie die eingebunden ist in die
Löscharbeiten Heiko
ja es gibt einen festgelegten Plan
wonach die Werksfeuerwehr in solchen
außen Ausnahmesituation sofort
verständigt wird und das sind die ersten
Leute die da auch vor Ort sind und die
diesen Brand angehen die sind
hochprofessionell organisiert das ist
auch Fortschritt dass es so eine
Werksfeuerwehr gibt und ich gehe davon
aus dass das genau die Feuerwehrleute
sind die da gerade am brandherz sind
oder an dieser Unglückstelle um ja das
Feuer zu löschen und die auch versuchen
die vermissten Arbeiter zu finden kannst
du noch mal ein kurzes Wort dazu sagen
Autobahn wurden ja gesperrt rund um
Leverkusen herum die Sperrung ist glaube
ich immer noch bestehend oder
ja genau das ist auch ganz leicht zu
verifizieren ich stehe hier neben der
Autobahnbrücke der A1 die A1 über den
Rhein ist Moment voll gesperrt gleiches
gilt für die A3 es ist nämlich hier ein
Autobahnkreuz wo die A1 die A3 kreuzt
und auch die A59 ist oder war zumindest
vor wenigen Minuten noch gesperrt das
Verkehrschaos dass ich hier anbahnt im
Rheinland das wird wahrscheinlich sehr
sehr groß werden da sich ja auch hier
noch zahlreiche Flutschäden befinden und
die Infrastruktur zurzeit ist wirklich
hart getroffen wer die Möglichkeit hat
sollte um diese Gegend also um das Kreuz
Leverkusen einen möglichst großen Bogen
machen das können wir gerade noch mal
auf der Karte zeigen hier liebe
Kolleginnen noch mal drauf schalten bei
mir auf den Rechner also es geht hier
also Heiko steht quasi hier an der A1
Autobahnbrücke
Neulandpark auf der einen Seite merken
nicht auf der anderen Seite und hier ist
einmal die A1 das ist komplett gesperrt
und hier fährt die A3 rechts des Rheins
also quasi östliches reins runter
Leverkusen Richtung Mülheim und auch da
ist es gesperrt dass es hier dieses
große Autobahnkreuz ich glaube das heißt
Spaghetti Knoten bei euch Heilkunde
dieser dieses Autobahnkreuz A1 A3 ne
genau richtig Spaghetti Knoten einfach
aufgrund der unglaublich vielen Fahrbahn
die sich hier treffen und ja das ist
einer der Verkehrsknotenpunkte in
Nordrhein-Westfalen wenn hier was schief
läuft oder wenn hier die Verbindung
nicht nicht funktioniert dann hat das
Auswirkungen auf ganz
Nordrhein-Westfalen vielleicht noch mal
ein kurzes Wort zu den Flutschäden gab
es die auch in Leverkusen irgendwie in
irgendeiner Form bei der Chemiepark
davon auch betroffen
der Chemiepark ist gegen flugschäden
besonders gesichert aber es gibt schon
Flutschäden hier um eine Umgebung aber
Leverkusen war jetzt nicht einer der
Schwerpunkte der Flut aber die Stadt
wurde schon auch von der Flut getroffen
und sind natürlich auch zahlreiche
Gebiete in der Nähe des Rheins matschig
die waren überflutet also wenn man jetzt
ja noch so ein Großereignis so ein
Großbrand hat dann wird das die ganze
Sache mit Sicherheit nicht vereinfachen
so und da kann ich die jetzt sagen was
wir gerade hier über die Agenturen
kriegen der Betreiber CURRENTA des
Leverkusener chemparks hat bestätigt das
ein vermisster Mitarbeiter tod
aufgefunden wurde vier weitere
Mitarbeiter werden noch vermisst wir
werden weiter dran bleiben Heiko Rams
wird für uns vor Ort bleiben mit dieser
traurigen Nachricht werden wir es aber
euch erstmal verabschieden denn das ist
der Stand der Dinge den wir euch
mitteilen können der Brand ist gelöscht
die große Rauchwolke über der Stadt hat
jetzt langsam aufgelöst aber wir haben
mittlerweile einen toten Mitarbeiter
und ich höre gerade wir warten jetzt
darauf dass die Pressekonferenz des
Betreibers in wenigen Minuten losgeht
ich schaue mal ob wir schon das
entsprechende Signal haben von den
Kolleginnen vom Westdeutschen Rundfunk
dass es noch nicht daran schaue ich
erstmal kurz in die Kommentare und
ansonsten warten wir hier einfach
gemeinsam weil das ist natürlich ein
muss man die da leider sagen wieder mal
tragisches Ereignis das haben wir in den
letzten Tagen ja doch häufiger hier über
den Sender bringen müssen jetzt auch
natürlich keine flugkatastrophe eine ja
chemie-katastrophe wissen wir noch nicht
welchen Ausmaßes auf jeden Fall ein
größerer Brand
ich schaue mal ob es bei euch
irgendwelche Fragen gibt also wir können
noch nicht so viel dazu sagen wir warten
daher jetzt mal auf die
Pressekonferenz die in wenigen Minuten
so wurde es angekündigt losgehen soll
kann aber noch ein bisschen dauernd
bleibt einfach im Stream und ihr kriegt
das dann mit wenn der Ton offen ist das
ist da losgeht
so es sieht so aus als ob das Mikrofon
wieder offen ist kurze Bestätigung aus
der Regie bitte Dankeschön also wir
warten hier darauf dass die
Pressekonferenz des Chemiepark
Betreibers in Leverkusen losgeht wann
das genau der Fall sein wird wissen wir
noch nicht wir haben den Stream einfach
mal offen gelassen damit ihr euch hier
versammeln könnt es gibt hier ein paar
fragen was genau passiert ist also heute
morgen um 9 Uhr gegen 9:40 Uhr es gibt
jetzt auch hier
User im Chat die schreiben auch nur 37
also gegen 9:40 Uhr hat es auf dem
Gelände des chemparks Leverkusen eine
Explosion gegeben soweit wir wissen in
der
Entsorgungsanlage es muss ein Tank
explodiert sein genaueres ist aber noch
nicht sicher es gibt verletzte und
mittlerweile hat der Betreiber
öffentlich bekannt gegeben unter anderem
auf Twitter dass es einen toten
Mitarbeiter gibt einer wurde tot
gefunden vier weitere werden noch
vermisst Weite von Leverkusen waren ja
in weiten Teilen von Leverkusen war
diese Rauchwolke zu sehen es wurde über
die warn-app Nina ein Alarm rausgegeben
dass alle Menschen in Leverkusen und im
Raum Leverkusen ins ja in geschlossene
Räume gehen sollen Fenster und Türen
geschlossen halten sollen Klimaanlagen
ausschalten sollen damit sie eben Zweige
giftige dämpfe nicht einatmen der
Verkehr über die Autobahn A1 und A3 der
da genau in der Nähe des Chemieparks
läuft ist eingestellt worden das heißt
die Autobahn sind zurzeit gesperrt ich
lese es hier auch schon Kommentare dass
es zu einem Verkehrschaos gerade kommt
und ja was was jetzt genau ob die
Strecken der Deutschen Bahn gesperrt
sind kann ich dir gerade nicht sagen
Ruben das sind jetzt so Fragen die hier
aufkommen und
was jetzt dort genau passiert ist das
wissen wir noch nicht darauf warten wir
wir können aber euch mitteilen dass das
Feuer wohl gelöscht wurde das heißt
diese große Rauchwolke die wir gesehen
haben vielleicht können die Kollegen an
der Regie die Kolleginnen in der Regie
das noch mal einspielen
wenn das so schnell vorliegt können wir
uns diese Bilder noch mal angucken es
war wirklich eine ziemlich große
Explosion in Leverkusen gab auch sofort
Bilder auf Twitter auf Instagram die
geteilt wurden die gezeigt haben was für
eine riesige Rauchwolke das war da sehen
wir es noch mal also diese Rauchwolke
stand mehrere Stunden über der Stadt
während das Feuer eben noch nicht unter
Kontrolle war
was genau in diesen dämpfen drin gewesen
ist können wir euch zur Stunde noch
nicht sagen es sind aber entsprechend
expert:innen unterwegs gewesen die die
Schadstoffe in der Luft gemessen haben
was dabei rausgekommen ist hoffen wir im
Laufe der nächsten Stunde zu erfahren
wenn die Pressekonferenz des Betreibers
losgeht mehrere Menschen wurden verletzt
teilweise schwer und ein
Mitarbeiter ist bei dem Unglück
gestorben vier weitere werden aber noch
vermisst und wir warten eben zur Stunde
auf die Pressekonferenz die der
Betreiber angekündigt hat
und wir schauen jetzt mal ob das WDR
Signal von den Kollegen vorliegt das ist
glaube ich aber immer noch nicht der
Fall aber ihr seht hier noch mal das ist
das pressekonferenzbild das heißt es ist
zumindest aufgebaut dass Signal steht
und ich würde sagen wir warten jetzt
einfach mal gemeinsam wann es losgeht es
kann sich jetzt eigentlich nur noch um
Minuten handeln
[Musik]
test test
test test test
1 2 3 test test
kommt nix gut
so also wir warten darauf die
Pressekonferenz wird wohl in wenigen
Minuten losgehen ich kann euch noch mal
kurz hier die Tweets vorlesen oder
zeigen die der campark Betreiber vor 20
Minuten abgesetzt hat also hat bestätigt
dass ein Mitarbeiter verstorben ist bei
dem Unglück viel weitere werden noch
vermisst 16 Mitarbeiter wurden verletzt
zwei davon schwer schreibt die Betreiber
Firma CURRENTA die Rettungsarbeiten
laufen weiter und es gab wohl auch
temporär die Gefahr dass die
Stromversorgung zusammenbricht im
kompletten Camp Park im kompletten
Chemiepark deswegen wurden auch alle
administrativ tätigen mitarbeiter:innen
vorsorglich evakuiert die Betriebe im
Chempark schreibt der Betreiber auf
Twitter wurden in einen sicheren Zustand
gebracht was auch immer das jetzt im
konkreten Fall heißt und es gibt eine
Hotline für die Bevölkerung also wenn
ihr im Raum Leverkusen wohnt und euch
informieren wollt ich weiß nicht ob
diese Hotline tatsächlich gut erreichbar
ist ich sage euch die Nummer trotzdem
mal das ist die
pro 1.4
260599333 noch mal zur mitschreiben
0214260599333 außerdem könnt ihr euch
bei Twitter weiter informieren die Seite
des chemparks also der Twitter Nick ist
ganz einfach@campark die geben laufend
neue Meldungen raus sobald etwas
Bekanntes was sie bekannt machen wollen
und wir warten jetzt weiter dass die
Pressekonferenz losgeht damit wir
weitere Einzelheiten erfahren es gab
jetzt hier schon Fragen im Chat wieso
weiß man denn nicht was da in der Luft
sein könnte man muss doch wissen was
dort verarbeitet wird es soll sich darum
ein entsorgungswerk gehandelt haben in
dem der Brand stattgefunden hat wo genau
wissen wir auch noch nicht es gab jetzt
die Informationen dass ein Tank
explodiert sein soll und wenn es ein
entsorgungswerk ist gehe ich jetzt mal
das leider davon aus dass hat dass dort
viele verschiedene Chemikalien entsorgt
werden und dann ist es natürlich
schwierig zu sagen welche davon ja jetzt
in die Luft sein könnten aber wir hoffen
dass hier in der nächsten halben Stunde
mehr Wissen eventuell kann das aber auch
noch länger dauern bis die Informationen
publik werden also
es scheint aber so zu sein dass die
Gefahr in Leverkusen erstmal gebannt ist
dass keine weiteren Tanks explodieren
können das Feuer soll unter Kontrolle
sein und auch die große Rauchwolke über
Leverkusen ist so nicht mehr zu sehen
aber natürlich zieht diese Wolke jetzt
weiter Richtung Bergisches Land das
heißt Richtung Osten oder Südosten von
Leverkusen ausgesehen die bewohner:innen
dort in den Gebieten werden weiterhin
gebeten nicht unbedingt auf Terrasse zu
gehen ist nicht sein muss die Fenster
geschlossen zu halten die Türen
geschlossen zu halten Klimaanlagen
auszuschalten einfach nur auf Nummer
sicher zu gehen so
was da genau schief gekauft gegangen ist
also gibt es den Kommentar von Mimi
Müller ein Tanklaster explodiert nicht
einfach mal so ob es ein Tanklaster ist
war es glaube ich nicht also es war mir
die Rede von einem
Tank nicht von einem Laster natürlich
explod einfach mal so was da genau
passiert ist aber bitte ich euch
wirklich jetzt von irgendwelchen
Spekulationen abzusehen ich habe auch
hier schon wieder jede Menge
verschwörungsmythen gelesen von denen
ich teilweise nicht weiß ob die ernst
gemeint sind aber auch das bringt uns
jetzt überhaupt nicht weiter und wir
schauen jetzt mal was bei der
Pressekonferenz passiert das Signal
liegt uns ja schon vor und dort sehen
wir schon jemanden der nach ja
offiziellem aussieht Stefan Hummel
Funktion kann ich euch gerade noch nicht
sagen wenn wir gleich erfahren aber die
Pressekonferenz scheint dann ja gleich
loszugehen und wir gehen mal auf das
Signal
Leverkusen von der feuerwehrseite in
Hermann Greven von der Berufsfeuerwehr
Leverkusen und der Steffen Hummel Pleite
der berufsunterricht
das finde ich Camper darf ich bitte zu
starten
ich nehme meine Maske ab ich glaube dann
bin ich etwas besser zu verstehen
nimm das Mikro mit in die Hand
[Musik]
so ich glaube da kann ich noch ein
bisschen runtergepegelt werden
sehr verehrte Damen und Herren
wir haben heute hier Leverkusen eine ich
muss wirklich klar sagen eine schwere
Stunde
wir haben eine eigenes bei dem wir einen
Toten zu beklagen haben
aufgrund einer Explosion in einem
Tanklager
in Buch gab es hier insgesamt 16
verletzte zwei davon schwer und ein
toter
wir vermissen noch vier Personen sind
auf der Suche
das ist eine für den Camper für uns als
Betreiber wirklich schwere Situation
unser Gedanke gilt an die Angehörigen
das ist auch hier eine Situation die wir
gemeinsam erstmal meistern müssen
hinsichtlich Einsatzablauf werden wir
gleich gerne Fragen und Abläufe geben
ich kann erst mal nur Danke an die
Einsatzkräfte und an die Stadt wir haben
hier sehr schnell alarmiert wir haben
die Stadt Leverkusen ein vollständig
eingebunden in die einsatzbearbeitung
wissen dass wir hier im Leverkusen dafür
gesorgt haben dass Menschen Angst haben
dass Menschen Befürchtungen haben und
wir setzen alles alles daran so schnell
als möglich diese Situation
zu beherrschen wir haben keine akute
Gefährdungslage aber wir haben immer
noch eine Gefährdungslage und sind hier
bemüht so schnell als möglich diese sehr
sehr konkret und durchzuarbeiten
durchzuarbeiten hört sich sehr
mechanisch an ich bin da wirklich
zutiefst die Betroffenen Verletzten und
vor allen Dingen den Verstorbenen
Mitarbeiter ich habe die Hoffnung dass
die vier noch vermissten
lebend gefunden werden
allerdings kann ich zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt da nur drüber spekulieren und
das tun wir an dieser Stelle bewusst
nicht erstmal mit diesem Anfang würde
ich gerne dann den Oberbürgermeister Uwe
Richrath einmal das Mikro und damit das
Wort auch weiterreichen
ja vielen Dank Herr Friedrich
ist ein tragischer Tag für Leverkusen
Leverkusen eine Stadt die engen
verwurzelt ist natürlich mit dem Camper
mit der Chemieindustrie wieder kennt die
chemischen industrieren Leverkusen jeder
in der Familie hat er auch vielleicht
schon Personen gehabt die hier
gearbeitet haben
die Gedanken der Stadt Leverkusen sind
bei der Familie des Getöteten
Mitarbeiter
und natürlich viel Kraft für die 16
verletzten zwei Feld Schwerverletzten
Mitarbeiterinnen Mitarbeitern ich wollte
morgen dann bisher zu Schaden gekommen
sind
ich habe das selber mitbekommen das war
eine immense Detonation im ganzen
Stadtgebiet ich habe auch teilweise
Leute angerufen aus dem Rhein nicht
bärchenkreis
wir haben die Sirenen gehört
die Ninas geschaltet worden und wichtig
ist
das trägt Verhaltensregeln dann auch von
den Bürgern angenommen worden sind wie
sagt man langer langer Industriestandort
ein tragischer Moment für Leverkusen
meine Gedanken sind jetzt noch bei den
vielen vielen Feuerwehrfrauen und
Männern die jetzt noch die Situation
bekämpfen um dann endgültig dann auch
die Situation im Griff zu haben ich
hoffe auch Herr Friedrich dass wir die
vier Personen noch finden Leben finden
da sind meine Gedanken jetzt bei dass
sie da rausgekommen sind mit diesen
Worten möchte ich dann das Mikro
weitergeben an Herrn Greven
ja schönen Tag meine Damen und Herren
von meiner Seite auch an dieser Stelle
möchte ich Ihnen auch die Betroffenheit
unserer Einsatzkräfte vor Ort sie können
sich vorstellen dass Szenario war auch
sehr beeindruckend für unsere
Einsatzkräfte und auch die Folgen für
die Betroffenen haben natürlich auch
Spuren bei unseren Einsatzkräften
hinterlassen also insofern auch hier
eine hohe Betroffenheit unser
Werkfeuerwehr vielleicht zwei drei Sätze
zum Einsatz Ablauf gegen 9 Uhr sind wir
durch ein Notruf aus dem
Entsorgungszentrum alarmiert worden wir
sind umgehend mit voller lahm also mit
allen Kräften die am Standort verfügbar
sind ausgerückt haben schon auf der
Anfahrt die Berufsfeuerwehr Leverkusen
zur Unterstützung mit alarmiert und dann
in Folge auch sehr schnell die Warnung
der Bevölkerung in Abstimmung mit der
Berufsfeuerwehr auch initiiert über die
bewährten Medien zum einen die
ninawan-app aber zum Anderen eben auch
die Sirenen die dann im Stadtgebiet
dafür sorgen dass die Bevölkerung auf
eine mögliche Gefährdung hingewiesen
wird wir waren dann sehr schnell vor Ort
Last Friedrich Herz schon angesprochen
die aktuelle Situation
hinsichtlich der Vermissten ist gerade
unser Einsatzschwerpunkt das bedeutet
hier sind wir mit allen Kräften und auch
gemeinsam mit den Kollegen der
Berufsfeuerwehr jetzt an der Suche der
Vermissten intensiv beteiligt und das
ist unser Einsatzschwerpunkt und darüber
hinaus natürlich die Sicherung der
Einsatzstelle das von dort aus keine
weiteren Gefährdungen ausgeht das soweit
von meiner Seite Hermann
[Musik]
vielen Dank ich kann mich und muss mich
den Worten meiner Vorredner zunächst
anschließend
hinsichtlich das
leider jetzt
Toten vermissten das belastet unsere
Arbeiten natürlich auch wir haben wie
die Werkfeuerwehr gerade schon
beschrieben hat
sehr zeitnah gemeinsam die
Einsatzabwicklung vor Ort aufgenommen
und haben den Schwerpunkt der Verletzten
Versorgung und verletzten Bergung
übernommen wir haben zwei
Schwerverletzte
nach einer Erstversorgung vor Ort in die
Krankenhäuser bringen können den
schwerst Verletzten nach Köln Merheim
und haben dann weiterhin gemeinsam mit
der Werkfeuerwehr
die Brandbekämpfung und weitere
Personensuche aufgenommen
so weit von mir
ihren Namen die Redaktion
was weiß man über die Wolke die für die
ganze Stadt zu sehen waren
also so ich bin ein bisschen
Lösungsmittel gebrannt es haben auch
chlorierte Lösungsmittel gebrannt und
eine genaue Analyse der Wolke die sich
ja in großer Höhe wir haben sie alle
gesehen in lieber Leverkusen gefunden
hat haben wir liegt uns zurzeit nicht
vor wir haben gemeinsam mit der Stadt
Leverkusen
Kollegen können gerne da ergänzen und
auch dem lanov im Grunde zu Vorsicht
weiter aufgerufen in Leverkusen um hier
in den Stadtteilen das ist im Krise
statt der Stadt auch festgelegt worden
das ist dann hörig und Opladen sehr
aufmerksam zu sein und hier in der ich
sag mal in der freien Natur außerhalb
der Wohnung im Grunde zu schauen ob da
Niederschläge wir achten darauf wir
haben auch Hotlines eingerichtet damit
die Bürger sich an dieser Stelle auch
melden können wenn sie Verdächtige
Niederschläge finden wenn so eine
Situation da ist können wir nur helfen
aufhören nicht diese Niederschläge
anzupacken Abstand davon zu halten der
Stadt oder dem Camp Park diese
Niederschläge zu melden so dass wir in
eine Bewertung reingehen können die wird
gemeinsam mit dem Lernen gemacht eine
Analytik da muss man aber sagen solche
umweltanalytiken dauern durchaus bis ein
paar Tage bis man da sehr sicher oder
ist sichere Ergebnisse hat das heißt wir
müssen da um Geduld bitten aber wir sind
deshalb haben wir auch die warenlage
noch nicht komplett zurückgenommen
gemeinsam weil wir sagen vorsicht ist
hier angesagt dass es ein vorsichtiges
Verhalten was in diesen Stadtteilen
bitte vom Bürger an den Tag legen gelegt
werden soll damit wir keine
Eigengefährdung an dieser Stelle haben
habt ihr noch Ergänzung
wir wissen momentan wir sind mit dem
Lauf in der Analytik und da wir nicht
genau wissen wie die zusammen
Ausstellung dort ist schließlich
momentan erstmal nichts aus weil das ist
einfach seriös und Spekulationen an
dieser Stelle zu diesem Einsatz
Zeitpunkt können wir einfach nicht
machen
also zur Ursache hoffentlich können Sie
es nachvollziehen können wir jetzt im
Grunde gar nicht sagen weil die
Einsatzkräfte haben jetzt einen
Schwerpunkt das ist noch Suche nach den
Vermissten und vorher kann man an dieser
Anlage gar keine Untersuchung machen das
ist noch ein laufender Einsatz und
deswegen können wir zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt noch gar keine Ursachen
Diskussion an dieser Stelle machen sind
wir nicht zu in der Lage
wir sind also jetzt in den betroffenen
Stadthallen mit Fahrzeugen unterwegs
führen Messungen durch immer mit
Unterstützung des lanoff also
zuständigen Umweltministeriums und ich
kann die Frage exakt noch nicht
beantworten also zurzeit gilt dort noch
bleiben Sie bitte in den Häusern und
halten sie weiter Fenster und Türen
geschlossen
ich gehe von Stunden aus
also es ist glaube ich üblich wenn Sie
das Stromleitungen und durch ganz
Deutschland gehen
lagersituation das Ereignis hat eine
Stromleitung die so eine klassische
Überlandleitung im Grunde beeinträchtigt
dadurch ist im Prinzip auch eine Leitung
runtergefallen durch das Ereignis und da
geht es natürlich dass die Einsatzkräfte
auch gesichert vorgehen müssen da geht
es um Gefährdung von Personal von
Menschen von Feuerwehrkollegen und
deswegen muss eine Leitung auch vorher
im Grunde dann sicher abgeschaltet
werden bevor die Kollegen in die
Einsatzstelle kommen deshalb muss man
hier eine gewisse ich sowas Schritt
Reinfolge einhalten das ist dann auch
gemacht worden in Absprache auch
durchaus mit Stromversorgung extern das
spielt ambrieren und Co immer
Ansprechpartner an dieser Stelle und das
im Prinzip umgesetzt worden dazu möchte
ich vielleicht direkt als anschließen
wir haben dann aufgrund dieser Strom ich
sag mal wie es immer Maßnahmen keine
Stromleitung runter zu nehmen unseren
Standort temporär nicht als gesichert
diesen kernstandort angesehen
diesbezüglich haben wir dann die
Produktion bei unseren Kunden drosseln
lassen damit der Stromverbrauch
untergeht und gleichzeitig wollten wir
konnten wir nicht ausschließen dass
vielleicht dieser Standort auch komplett
stromlos wird das war die Ursache dass
ich gebeten habe alle Mitarbeiter die
hier nicht für Produktion Sicherheit und
Technik zuständig sind sondern zum
Beispiel administrationskräfte alle nach
Hause zu schicken weil wenn dann der
Strom ausgefallen wäre hätte ich nicht
noch zig Mitarbeiter ja haben wollen
also es gab das war die Diskussion die
man teilweise auch in den Social Media
verfolgen konnte es gab also keine
Räumung dieses Standortes aufgrund des
Ereignisses im Bericht sondern wegen den
nicht vor gesicherten Stromversorgung
haben wir vorsorglich die Mitarbeiter
gebeten nach Hause zu gehen das war im
Prinzip mal der Grund warum wir Teil
Mitarbeiter des kernstandortes hier
gebeten haben den Arbeitsplatz zu
verlassen
also wir reden hier im Nordbereich des
campparkstandortes von unserem
integrierten Entsorgungszentrum dort
befinden sich drei Bereiche es ist
einmal die gemeinschaftskinderanlage mit
der Stadt Leverkusen und das chemparks
darüber die Deponie und dann die
sonderabfallverbrennungsanlage die hier
betroffen war sind also drei Betriebe
wir haben also hier unser
Entsorgungszentrum an dieser Stelle
nördlich der autobahnknotens
aus dem Stand kann ich nicht sagen wie
viel Mitarbeiter genau aber damit sie
eine Abschätzung haben ich gehe davon
aus dass in Summe an solch einem Tag so
rund 50 60 Mitarbeiter in der
Größenordnung dort in diesem
standortkomplex beschäftigt sind so eine
Größenordnung ohne dass ich mir jetzt
hier genau auf eine Zahl festlegen
sollte
so das der erstmal der es gibt ein
schwer verletzten der in mehr heim mit
schweren Brandverletzungen dort ist dort
muss es wirklich sind die Verletzung
wirklich sehr ernsthaft
also Lebensgefahr ist wirklich real
vorhanden die Identität des Toten da die
ist noch nicht abschließend sicher
geklärt und bevor die nicht sicher
geklärt ist dass wir wirklich diese
Identität haben und auch die Angehörigen
informiert haben da haben wir eine klare
Regel bevor wir irgendwie Identitäten
irgendwo ist eine angehörigeninformation
die erste Pflicht und die werden wir
auch vornehmen bevor wir hier über
Identitäten oder spekulieren können oder
auch veröffentlichen
da ist die Einfahrt nein ganz einfach
weil Deponie genau das andere
Betriebsbereich diese beiden Themen
haben nichts miteinander zu tun das kann
man sicher ausschließen
also wir haben hier einen Tanklager bei
dem die
Produktionsabfälle des Standortes
zwischengelagert werden um dann in der
sonderverbrennungsanlage verbrannt zu
werden in diesem Tanklager befinden sich
mehrere Tanks die im Grunde dann unter
die haben alle maximalfüllstände und
dann haben die einen realfüllstand wir
reden aber von Tanks in einer großen
Ordnung von 3 bis 400 Kubikmetern das
ist die Größenordnung von der wir reden
und wir reden hier von drei Tanks die
betroffen waren
und wie gesagt Lösungsmittel das sind
organische Lösungsmittel als
Produktionsabfälle unserer Camper Kunden
genau also welcher Tank da ursächlich
der aus- oder an welcher Stelle das
Ereignis ausgelöst wurde das können wir
auch zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt nicht
beantworten alle drei Tanks sind vom
Ereignis entweder komplett oder in
Teilen zerstört und waren in den
Brandgeschehen beteiligt
wie viel Produkt war denn da drin ist
wie viel wieder Kubikmeter Tonnen
also wir haben Vorstände werden
da drin sind also wir gehen davon aus
was wir im Prinzip bis jetzt
recherchiert haben aber das war auch
noch nicht Schwerpunkt unserer
Tätigkeiten gerade dass wir hier in den
Tanks Fülle gerade von 200 bis 300
Kubikmetern je Tank im Grunde haben wie
viel davon jetzt wirklich verbrannt ist
wie viel in die Auffangsystem auch hier
haben wir Sicherheitssysteme in den
Tankanlagen dort aufgefangen worden ist
das ist genau gerade der Schwerpunkt in
der einsetzbearbeitung vorne vor Ort
hier ist das Thema
löschwasserrückhaltung die sie haben wir
komplett sichern können das heißt da hat
kein Löschwasser irgendwie den Standort
oder den durchkomplex verlassen dass es
alles vor Ort im Grunde aufgefangen
worden und wird jetzt im Grunde dann
analysiert und den Absprache mit den
Behörden dann im Grunde entweder weiter
entsorgt was Wasser wird ja nicht
dauerhaft bleiben da muss man dann
entsorgen vornehmen
jetzt speziell
also erstmal gilt ja nach wie vor im
Haus zu bleiben
und wenn sich sowas auftut wie sie
geschildert haben dann haben wir eine
Hotline geschaltet CURRENTA wird auch
eine geschaltet haben
die 406 und viermal die drei und dort
kann sich dann der betroffene Bürger die
betroffene Bürgerin
informieren bzw
aufklären lassen
ja von meiner Seite eine Maus ist auch
gesagt worden dass wir jetzt nur absolut
im vorsichtsbereich arbeiten das heißt
wir werden als Stadt Leverkusen jetzt
den Bürgen Opladen das sind die beiden
Bereiche die eben davon auch betroffen
sind da werden wir die Spielplätze
schließen das wird jetzt in dem Moment
passieren und wir werden natürlich die
Bürger Aufrufen in diesem Bereichen dann
auch wenn sie im Garten Obst haben
dieses Obst oder Gemüse abzuwaschen das
sind Vorsichtsmaßnahmen sie haben gehört
Tesla wir sind unterwegs ist geht jetzt
darum die Substanzen zu analysieren und
jeder Bürger der etwas sieht was nicht
ganz normal ist oder sich bitte melden
dann würden wir das auch analysieren um
zum Schluss natürlich zu schauen was
sind da für Substanzen darunter gekommen
sind jetzt geht es erstmal darum
maximalen Schutz Sensibilität
kinderplätze werden geschlossen das
gartenobst soll dann abgewaschen werden
vor dem Verzehr die Analyse läuft dann
eben zu einem späteren Zeitpunkt
also die Pressekonferenz die eilig
einberufen wurde von der Stadt
Leverkusen dem Betreiber CURRENTA dieses
Chemieparks und den der Feuerwehr der
Berufsfeuerwehr und der
Betriebsfeuerwehr ist jetzt zu Ende ich
kann euch noch mal kurz zusammenfassen
was dort im Wesentlichen gesagt wurde
also für den Betreiber corenta hat Herr
Friedrich gesprochen der hat gesagt es
gab also irgendeine Explosion im
Tanklager heute Morgen gegen 9:40 Uhr
was dort genau passiert ist ist immer
noch unklar drei Tanks sind komplett
oder teilweise zerstört darin haben sich
chlorierte in Klammern Lösungsmittel
Befunden die sind Produktionsabfälle der
dort ansässigen
Chemiepark Kunden also das ist ja quasi
ein Chemiepark wo man sich als Firma
einmieten kann und dort kann man dann
seine Abfälle wohl abgeben und die
werden dann dort entsorgt
die Zusammensetzung des Brandes ist aber
noch unbekannter wollte Herr Friedrich
nicht spekulieren was da genau noch
weiter verbrannt ist die traurige
Nachricht es gibt 16 verletzte zwei
davon schwer es gibt einen Toten der
noch nicht identifiziert wurde und vier
Menschen werden noch vermisst dort sind
sich ja die
Betreiberfirma und die Berufsfeuerwehr
nicht sicher ob sie sie lebensbergen
können oder ob sie sich in Sicherheit
bringen konnten aber natürlich haben sie
noch Hoffnung dass diese vielen Menschen
lebend aufgefunden werden
die Berufsfeuerwehr hat sich auch sehr
betroffen gezeigt gesagt das war ein
ziemlich großer Einsatz genau wie die
Werksfeuerwehr wir können aber jetzt
schon sagen erste Luftmessungen der
umweltschutzeinheiten im Kölner Norden
haben heute Mittag ergeben dass es wohl
keine weitere Gefahr gerade gibt für die
Bevölkerung zumindest im Kölner Norden
nicht es wird aber weiter gemessen und
ja jetzt können wir einfach nur noch mal
zu meinem Kollegen nach Leverkusen
schalten Heiko du bist für uns noch vor
Ort ich guck mal ob die Leitung steht
Heiko ist Heiko Rams weiterhin dort das
Chemiewerk ist hinter dir vielleicht
kannst du aus deiner Sicht noch mal
zusammenfassen wie es die Situation dort
vor Ort gerade ist hörst du noch
Einsatzwagen ist die Sperrung der
Autobahn weiter bestehend
ja also bis die die Sperrung der
Autobahn besteht wohl noch teilweise
hinter mir ist die A1 zu sehen zurzeit
höre ich da kein Verkehr ich gehe also
davon aus dass diese Autobahn weiter
gesperrt ist auf der A3 und auf der A59
die sich ja auch hier in unmittelbarer
Nähe befinden dort sehen wir schon
wieder Autos die Rollen zumindest auf
der A59 wir gehen davon aus dass dort
der Verkehr wieder regulär freigegeben
ist hier sind immer noch zahlreiche
Rettungskräfte unterwegs und es werden
laufend Luftmessungen genommen halt um
sicherzustellen und um mir
herauszufinden ob sich eine
schadstoffwolke vom Werk aus weiter
verbreitet und möglicherweise die
Menschen weiter gefährdet die Warnung
für die Anwohner weiterhin Fenster und
Türen geschlossen zu halten die
Klimaanlage auszuschalten und zu warten
dass diese Situation vorübergeht diese
Warnung ist weiter
und sie gilt auch vor allen Dingen in
Richtung Bergisches Land wohin wohl
diese schadstoffwolke gezogen ist hier
ist ein interessante Frage die in ja
mehrerer Formen schon aufgekommen ist
quasi warum ist so ein Chemiewerk so nah
an der Stadt hier mal zugespitzt warum
darf eigentlich ein störfallbetrieb wie
eine Chemie Fabrik mitten in der Stadt
errichtet werden ich glaube mitten in
der Stadt ist sie nicht aber in der Nähe
der Stadt und für Windkraftanlagen
gelten 1000 Meter oder mehr
Abstandsregel also ist das ein ein
Diskussion auch in der Region mal
gewesen ob diese Chemiestandort zu nah
an Wohnorten liegt
das sind natürlich hier historisch
gewachsene Strukturen der
Chemiestandort hier den gibt es schon
ganz ganz lange hier wurden unter
anderem Rüstungsgüter schon für den
Ersten Weltkrieg erzeugt für den
folgenden Weltkrieg auch die
Hinterlassenschaften aus dieser Zeit
befinden sich in der größten
Giftmülldeponie Europas auch die ist
hinter mir zu sehen unterhalb dieses
Berges es ist ein sehr sehr sensibles
Gebiet wahrscheinlich würde man heute
wenn man diese Anlage neu errichten
würde dass natürlich nicht mehr in
unmittelbarer Nähe der Wohnbebauung noch
mal tun aber jetzt steht hier jetzt
steht hier normal alles und alle
Strukturen sind gewachsen und
bisher klappte das Zusammenleben
einigermaßen gut aber klar es ist mit
gewissen Risiken verbunden und das haben
wir auch heute wieder gesehen kannst du
dich an einen ähnlichen Vorfall erinnern
den es mal gegeben hat also ist ist es
tatsächlich ein ein ich sag mal ein
singuläres er ist ein großes ein großer
eigener was das so noch nicht gegeben
hat oder gibt es immer mal wieder auch
Vorkommnisse dieser Art
natürlich gibt es immer wieder Störfälle
bei so großen Anlagen aber was ihr heute
passiert ist das ist schon sehr
ungewöhnlich da kann ich mich an kein
ähnlichen Vorfall erinnern aber
natürlich Unfälle in so großen
Chemieanlagen die gibt es immer wieder
das zeigt die Historie ich erinnere mich
an den Brand in Sanders vor vielen
Jahren der zu einer Umweltkatastrophe
geführt hat Chemieanlagen sind nun mal
immer Risiken risikobehaftet und das ist
eben die Sache auf die man sich einlässt
wenn man solche Anlagen betreibt so hier
nochmal die Bitte an alle in den
Kommentaren sachlich zu bleiben
irgendwelche Spekulationen zu
unterlassen haben die Betreiber auch
gerade
darum gebeten also sie werden nicht
spekulieren was dort genau passiert ist
was verbrannt wurde das werden die
nächsten Stunden zeigen hier gab es noch
mal die Frage Heiko wie sich jetzt die
AnwohnerInnen und anwohnerverhalten
sollen in und um Leverkusen auch
Richtung Bergisches Land Bergisch
Gladbach herum
ja vor allen Dingen die Einwohner oder
die Menschen die auf der Wind
abgewandten Seite von diesem Unglücksort
wohnen sollten weiterhin Türen und
Fenster geschlossen haben wenn
Klimaanlagen laufen bitte ausschalten
damit die Außenluft nicht von außen dann
doch in die Wohnungen hinein gelangt und
weiterhin die Medien verfolgen
beziehungsweise auf die warn-app Nina
schauen dort werden aktuelle
Informationen verbreitet wie sich die
Bevölkerung verhalten soll aber im
Moment raten die Behörden dazu
vorsichtig zu sein und sich in
geschlossenen Räumen aufzuhalten Heiko
du stehst zum Glück auf der nicht
zugewandten Seite das heißt du kriegst
eine etwaige Giftwolke nicht mit das
noch mal an alle also macht euch keine
Sorgen unseren Kollegen da hat er drauf
aufgepasst deswegen kann er sich auch
draußen aufhalten Heiko Douglas weiter
für uns vor Ort beobachtest die Lage ich
bedanke mich dafür dass du hier uns so
schnell zur Verfügung gestanden hast ich
bedanke mich bei Euch für die auf
Wirksamkeit und für die fragen uns sag
jetzt erstmal zu diesem Thema machen wir
den Stream zu wir werden schauen was ich
im Laufe des Tages ergibt ob wir noch
mal live gehen werden wenn es neue
dramatische Entwicklungen geben sollte
ansonsten sage ich jetzt erstmal vielen
Dank fürs zusehen für die Aufmerksamkeit
bis später tschüss